okay I'm giving in rockland from the
Financial Times and I've just finished
moderating the session on historic
complexity featuring three historians
and it's a kind of session I think the
Davos is particularly useful for because
of course there are all sorts of
discussions and issues of the day when
they can nominate a call scientific or
political but you also have really
interesting minds professors from all
over the world and I particularly enjoy
the ones where you could take a slightly
more abstract look and what we did today
was to look at different versions
different ways of studying history we
had um professor called David Christian
who is highly of something that equals
big history it always takes mankind out
of history books of history as it
unfolded over millennia and the big
environmental and biological changes we
had Jim Glick who's a specialist in
technology who argues that the things
that have really changed history haven't
been so much men as different
technological breakthroughs for example
he talked about the investment of
telegraph in the 19th century and then
about how computers and computerization
is changing history today and we had
professor HW brands at the University of
Texas and the man has been consulted by
President Obama among others on more
recent and more if you like conventional
history he's written historic histories
of my options of Franklin Roosevelt of
Teddy Roosevelt and histories of
financial crises and it was I thought a
fascinating discussion because it showed
how different perspectives on past can
illuminate the present and I think just
the kind of thing that Davos is
particularly fit up